this video is brought to you by nordvpn
when was it the last time you added a
new move to your training for some it
will have been years maybe you've just
stuck with a few common exercises you'll
always see in bodybuilding magazines
maybe you've stuck with the big three
lifts and a few accessories in all
likelihood one of the best things you
can do for your Fitness right now would
be to try something new learn a new
martial arts move a new dance move a new
lift how about the pistol squat or
Turkish getup or a makako how about
trying rock climbing wild swimming or
Jiu Jitsu you can have a go at juggling
or try and learn a movement from break
dancing because Fitness is about more
than just strength and cardio it's about
being able to move your body with great
control and confidence by experimenting
with new movements in your training
you'll increase your movement
intelligence you'll gain greater control
over your body and you'll strengthen
muscles you never even knew you had
because every New Movement you
experiment with is an education learning
even a more basic plant progression for
example will teach you about straight
arm strength perhaps this is something
you've not experimented with before but
developing it can lead to reduced chance
of bicep tear during things like the
deadlift and greater strength than a
whole range of different movements
you'll also need to develop a rock solid
core scapular control and much more
you'll learn so much more about yourself
just by trying to learn this move
in ballet you'll learn about positioning
the pelvis ask many people if they have
an anterior pelvic tilt and they won't
be able to answer a ballet dancer on the
other hand can literally position their
pelvis wherever they like
the kind of postural control a ballet
dancer learns can help them to move more
gracefully powerfully and with longevity
and there's no reason you can't learn a
plie or another move from ballet in your
spare time
the kettlebell swing meanwhile teaches
the hip hinge it teaches you to relax
and contract your body as needed and it
teaches you to deal with unpredictable
weights I could go on and on each time
you try a new movement that seems Out Of
Reach you force yourself to learn new
Concepts and to control your body in new
ways that translates to Greater control
and power in other movements faster
acquisition of new skills as you start
to understand the language of movement
and you're greatly lessen your chance of
injury
if you're going to be learning new
skills online then you need a VPN like
today's sponsor nordvpn the nordvpn is a
VPN that's a virtual private Network and
basically what this is is it's a method
to relay your internet traffic via a
server located elsewhere which is a
great way to protect your personal
information and at the same time to
unlock some new features on a few of
your favorite apps nordvpn is the
fastest VPN according to the most recent
speed tests but it means that if anyone
spies on your internet activity all
they're going to see is that you loaded
up this VPN that way you protect your
information and at the same time it
means that if you want to watch
something like Netflix you can do so
whilst spoofing your address you can
make it look as though you're coming
from a different country by choosing a
server located in that region and the
reason you might want to do this is so
that you can access content that's
region locked and nordvpn is a really
good one with tons of different apps
it's really easy to use and it has a
bunch of different features as well that
help to improve your security in other
ways if you think this sounds good and
you're interested in trying out nordvpn
for yourself then bioneer viewers can
get access to an exclusive deal by going
to nordvpn.com forward slash the bioneer
link in the description down below
there's also a 30 day money back
guarantee so there's no risk to you why
not give it a try thanks again to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video thanks
to you guys for watching and let's carry
on with the show shall we
and because you'll be training parts of
your body you're not used to you'll make
incredible gains and smash through
plateaus training the same exercise over
and over again will always yield
diminishing returns there's only so much
better you can get at the bench press
eventually you'll find you can't create
much of a stimulus for growth without
adding unwieldy amounts of weight and
you really need that much weight on the
same single move so why not try a day of
Medal slams and see how you feel the
next morning try something new that
makes you feel like a noob again and
that means Noob gains
can you do a skin the cat can you do a
muscle up I spent the day yesterday
attempting to learn the tornado kick
from Grant today my thighs and hips feel
like they've had an insane workout I
didn't even lift any weight my friend
tells me about a time he spent over an
hour on monkey bars and he had the most
insane Dums in his abs the next day and
this was a guy who trained his abs
regularly not only can this novelty
result in genuine strength and physique
gains that apply more generally it also
helps the body to make more connections
to strengthen those weak links and to
build a far more Dynamic physicality
and what's more is that learning
something new is fun many people find
training boring this makes a lot of
sense when you consider that they're
literally repeating the same movement
over and over and over again that
boredom is your brain's way of telling
you that this isn't optimal Behavior by
introducing new elements and trying new
things you can create the type of
Engagement and cognitive stimulation
that makes you actively focus on what
you're doing makes you want to do it
makes it addictive I've been trying to
learn some new skipping skills on and
off lately the process is fun in the
same way a computer game is fun it has
the one more try factor meaning you can
improve your cardio without needing some
insane willpower because it's something
you actively want to do
the same goes for sparring for focused
mitts for the learning new dance
routines the slack lining for rock
climbing these are really fun things the
brain and body literally crave this kind
of stimulation the brain is a learning
machine which is why we find this type
of learning inherently fun
moreover this kind of constant learning
puts the brain in a more plastic State
they say you can't teach an old dog new
tricks that's largely because most old
dogs stopped trying to learn new tricks
long ago they literally lost the ability
to learn as a result they found their
comfort zone and stayed there when you
keep learning and keep trying new things
your brain stays more youthful and you
find it increasingly easier to learn new
things nothing accomplishes this quite
like moving in 3D space
then comes the reward of learning
something new and the awesome feeling of
having a bag of tricks you can draw from
at any time with more physical skills
you'll be able to thrive in more
situations engage in more activities
explore more and you'll have a ton of
neat party tricks too
now of course there are downsides to
this idea if you're constantly learning
new things in a scatter shot manner how
are you supposed to progress how can you
master one skill if you keep moving on
to the next well for starters I'm not
saying you should only keep adding new
things to your training you can maintain
a steady training program while still
trying a new move every other week or so
while also occasionally trying a new
sport or a new class there's plenty of
time for both approaches to work over
time you'll discover new and more
exciting ways to train that become
Mainstays
you can add them to your regular
training the rest you can discard
eventually your routine will be full of
movements that you love and can't wait
to train as Bruce Lee would say absorb
what is useful discard what is useless
and add what is specifically your own at
the same time as long as there's some
consistency in the traits attributes and
networks being trained you can
experiment without losing much progress
so for example if you train push-ups one
week and try learning lizard crawls the
next week you'll be hitting the pecs
hard at both times there is consistency
here it's just not precisely the same
movement this is repetition without
repetition and for real Dynamic movement
it is in many ways Superior
of course if you're experimenting with
new moves to the detriment of precise
repetition with others then it could
take some time and energy away from your
regular training that might mean your
strength increases more slowly on key
lifts or that you don't pack on quite as
much muscle quite as quickly but as I
often say as I often argue on this
channel this isn't necessarily a bad
thing I think it's a great trade-off in
fact
[Music]
you'll get stronger a little slower but
in exchange you'll increase your
movement IQ you'll gain a ton of awesome
new skills and movements to add your
repertoire you'll be strong in ways that
other people miss and you'll be excited
for your training again
[Music]
foreign
so yeah try something new
[Music]
and if you want to try a routine that
incorporates a lot of unique movements
from a wide variety of styles then be
sure to check out my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
you'll get a massive ebook you'll get
over two hours of video tutorials and
you're trained in a way that improves
everything from ability to strength to
cardio to body control using a wide
variety of exercises but that can be
adapted to any situation and any skill
level
I want to say a massive thanks to Grant
Stevens and Liam Ellis for being big
part of this video and if you're a
YouTuber based in the UK and you need
someone to come and film your work then
I highly recommend Liam he's available
and he's incredibly skilled great guy so
you can find his Link in the description
down below
check out Grant's Channel if you want to
learn how to do some of those awesome
martial arts moves subscribe and you'll
make sure you won't miss that
a massive thank you to Paul Clutterbuck
for letting me use his gym first for
Fitness in bista check it out and some
of this was also filmed at Anytime
Fitness also in Vista and a massive
thank you to them I think that's all the
shout outs done oh yeah thanks so much
to you guys for watching this one and
I'll see you next time
bye for now